it's been a long time since Mike Myers
took us on a groovy journey through time
and espionage with his Austin Powers
franchise a three-film romp that
featured a star-studded cast of past and
future celebrities in the decades since
some of these actors have hung on to
their mojo while others are resting on
their laurels here's a look back at
where the cast was before the films and
where they are now Mike Myers before he
played Austin Powers dr. evil and the
endlessly hungry fat bastard Mike Myers
played a slew of characters during his
six-year run on Saturday Night Live
including metal head Wayne Campbell who
of course appeared in his own feature
film franchise once the Austin Powers
trilogy ended Myers went on to voice the
beloved title character in the Shrek
franchise but sadly his other work
wasn't as well-received 2008's The Love
Guru won a terrible trifecta of Razzie
Awards for worst actor or screenplay and
worst picture plus the nomination for
Myers for worst actor of the decade abs
baby very still Myers has left his mark
on Hollywood his Walk of Fame star was
unveiled in 2002 and in his home country
of Canada he's a national hero with his
own commemorative stamp and if you're
more likely to see him in a Toronto
Maple Leafs game than on the big screen
these days it might be because the
Austin Powers and Trek franchises
combined made him even wealthier than
dr. evil
Elizabeth Hurley this English actress is
probably best known for her role as
Vanessa Kensington in the first two
Austin Powers films but those are just a
pair of entries the lengthy filmography
that includes movies like rowing with
the wind and bedazzled where she plays a
smokin hot devil and off-screen Hurley
is famous in her own right for her
modeling work and by association for her
13-year relationship with Hugh Grant
standing by him during the 1995 scandal
in which Grant was caught with a
Hollywood prostitute I did a bad thing
and that they have it these days Hurley
is flying solo and staying busy running
a beachwear company and playing Queen
Helena on the E television series the
Royals Michael York long before Austin
Powers hit theaters the English actor
who plays Basile exposition was a
veteran of stage and screen since the
mid-1960s
starring in films like Taming of the
Shrew in Romeo and Juliet and on
Broadway in the original production of
Tennessee Williams outcry and don't even
get us started on his television credits
York reprised his role for all three
Austin Powers films but since 2010 the
actor has rarely been seen on screen and
has been undergoing treatment for
amyloidosis a rare medical condition
caused by the abnormal production of
insoluble proteins in the body Mimi
Rogers Austin Powers international man
of mystery is merely a side note on the
resume of this actress producer and
competitive poker player who famously
starred in the 1991 religious drama the
rapture after the first Austin Powers
movie Rodgers went on to appear in films
like lost in space and Ginger Snaps and
a popular television shows including the
x-files and Mad Men Robert Wagner long
before he starred as dr. Evil's
right-hand man Robert Wagner was one of
the hardest working actors in Hollywood
who does number two work for pretty much
everyone
Wagner starring roles include TV shows
like it takes a thief switch and heart
to heart and in the 21st century you
could find him on Two and a Half Men and
NCIS
but Wagner might be most famous for his
role in one of classic Hollywood's
biggest tragedies in 1981 Wagner's
oscar-nominated wife Natalie Wood
drowned while sailing off the coast of
California with Wagner and actor
Christopher Walken Woods death was ruled
an accident but lingering questions
about the
possibility of foul play resulted in the
investigation being reopened in 2013
with a Los Angeles coroner's office
amending the actress cause of death to
include undetermined factors the
decision to reopen the investigation was
supported by Wagner who's still mourning
his wife's death more than 30 years
later well I don't think he'd ever
overcome it and why should you Seth
Green after he played dr. Evil's son
Scott in all three Austin Powers movies
Hollywood was only too happy to throw a
freaking boon to Seth Green 20 years
after he refused to hug his evil dad on
screen Green has found massive success
as a creator and producer writer
director and main vocal talent of Adult
Swim's stop-motion sketch comedy show
Robot Chicken Green was also a staple of
comedies like can't hardly wait and
without a paddle and has been heard but
not seen as the voice of Family Guy's
Chris Griffin and with various
prestigious awards under his belt for
his work on Robot Chicken this is one
Austin Power Star who hasn't lost his
mojo since 1997 Mindy sterling
although sterling got her start playing
with puppets on the children's TV series
Dusty's treehouse it's her role as dr.
Evil's associate frau farbissina where
she truly made her mark on hollywood's
hearts and eardrums so you probably
won't recognize sterling from anywhere
else unless you watch TV with your kids
the spider street cred is evils girl
Friday the actress is a popular casting
pick on Disney Nickelodeon and other
children's networks where her comedy
credentials definitely make her well
suited for family-friendly roles
Will Ferrell after notching his big
screen breakthrough in Austin Powers The
Spy Who shagged me Mike Myers fellow SNL
veteran became a comedy star in his own
right
bringing laughs and films like
old-school anchorman and Talladega
Nights I'm the best there is plain
simple I mean I wake up in the morning
excellent Ferrell also had one of the
most memorable runs in Saturday Night
Live history where he became famous for
impersonating famous figures like george
w bush cubs announcer harry carey and
jeopardy host Alex Trebek nowadays he's
still making movies
and making fun of himself often to earn
money for charitable causes as with his
10 major league baseball teams in one
day stunt from 2015 Heather Graham way
before she played felicity shagged well
in the Austin Powers sequel Heather
Graham broke out in Hollywood in the
late 1980s with license to drive
followed by Twin Peaks and Boogie Nights
and after traveling back to 1969 for the
Spy Who shagged me Graham didn't slow
down
after playing felicity shagged well
Graham went on to star in films like
committed say it isn't so and The
Hangover series and more recently she's
been featured in recurring roles on
series like show times Californication
and Netflix's flaked I'm treating enough
to be on TV right Beyonce unless you've
been living under a rock this is one
Austin Powers alumna who needs no
introduction the 22 time Grammy Award
winner is one of America's top 50
richest self-made women with more than
100 million records sold worldwide and
that's just her solo career but the
majority of Beyonce success came after
she played leading lady foxy Cleopatra
in Austin Powers in Goldmember even if
she was already well on her way to
superstardom by then as the lead singer
of Destiny's Child Michael Kane this
icon of the British screen has been
acting since the 1950s and he was an
Oscar nominee long before he played
Austin Powers father in Goldmember Katy
worked steadily throughout the 1970s and
80s starring in films like Get Carter
and Woody Allen's hannah and her sisters
for which she earned the first of two
Academy Awards for Best Supporting Actor
but since he showed the world where
Austin got his groove Keane is probably
best known for his work with director
Christopher Nolan particularly in his
role as Alfred Pennyworth in the Dark
Knight trilogy where as Nolan's favorite
cast member he had all the best lines
some men just want to watch - well done
Verne Troyer though he's best known for
playing the miniature clone of dr. evil
Verne Troyer as a big presence in
Hollywood the 2 feet 8 inch tall actor
has brought his unique statute of films
like Pinocchio's revenge and
mightyjoyoung and he was the first to
play Griphook the Goblin and Harry
Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone though
he was replaced later in films by fellow
actor and friend Warwick Davis Troyer
also maintains an active social media
presence where he's recently admitted to
battling alcohol addiction and thanked
his fans for their support Fred Savage
so yo them part from his bid is a spy
with a prominent mole in Goldmember
there's one role that will follow Fred
Savage for the rest of his life of
course we're talking about The Wonder
Years where the young actor earned two
Golden Globe nominations and two Emmy
nominations for playing the lead role of
Kevin Arnold although yes that's also
him in The Princess Bride giving the
stink eye to all things romantic kissing
look after his role in the Austin Powers
franchise Savage moved on to mostly
voice acting with appearances on Family
Guy Kim Possible and Bojack horseman and
he's kept busy behind the camera as a TV
director but if you're dying to see his
face on screen without that mole in the
way he's also getting back into acting
with starring roles in both seasons of
the grinder and the Netflix series
friends from college thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]